the heading is line of best fit where it
does one of the most important things in
the topic of data just like why is it
useful is you can often use it to
predict things when you don't have done
right so you look at a bunch of people
and you're like oh I have a measurement
about them I can work out measurements
about other people who I haven't met who
I have a survey I haven't measured
whatever by virtue of the data that I do
have right so a line of best fit is a
great tool to help us predict things
you're going to need to grab your ruler
for this here is your scatterplot and
what I want to do is draw a line a
straight line for us there are lives
that best fit that I'm straight but
they're much more complicated to work
out I want to draw a straight line that
sort of approximate this data okay
obviously all the data doesn't fit on
exactly one straight line so
everything's not going to be on there
but it'll be close so here's what I want
you to do once you've got your 10 data
points on there I now let you have your
ruler and I want you to try and place it
along the data so that you are as close
to all of the data points as possible
okay move around shift around if you
watch on the board this is what I'm
going to try and do I'm going to imagine
this is my ruler to see how is that
benefiting so I'm going to magic this is
my rule then I'm going to wave around
until I'm reasonably happy with how it
close weight fits the data I've got so
I'm going to put it somewhere like that
okay now yours might be slightly
different something I was going to
explain a little bit later on but
actually is beyond the scope of what we
need to do this year is that there's a
way to technically accurate and work out
where this line is
we're just doing a line of best fit by I
so therefore there's a good chance for
the line that you draw will be slightly
different to the one other person next
to you and that's okay
so what you once you're comfortable with
it before you market I want you to note
a couple of things you might like to jot
this down underneath to get a good line
of best fit a good line of best if there
are three particular really two
particular things that I want to look
for okay you might want to drop these
down as a little dot place underneath
your RAM firstly you'd like to pass
through as many points as possible pass
through as many points as possible
feedback - yesterday we talked about the
relationship between two variables in
bivariate data if everything was on a
perfect straight line then your line of
best fit would have all of the points on
it but we don't usually get every single
one so you just wanted median possible
you can see the one that I've drawn I
sort of have like one two three Green a
bit okay
and that's not too bad given like
there's only ten nine points there you
want a classroom as many points as
possible
but in addition to that you want
approximately approximately the same
number of points above your line of best
fit as there are below the line of best
fit
let me say that again no writer you want
approximately the same number of points
above and below
so you can see because my line of best
fit early hits three of the points some
are on top and some are below i but we
can count one two three four I guess
that are above and I've got one two
three that are below ish okay again
because we're just doing it by eye this
is not going to be exact but it's person
up I'm pretty happy with that okay
overall what are we trying to do
actually maybe this is also worth
writing down so third and final point
let me just make a bit more space for
myself there we go
the third and final thing which I guess
is summarize what you're trying to do is
your trade - yes oh you can't do that on
your board you're trying to minimize it
this is an important phrase you're
trying to minimize the total distance
from all of your data points or ten of
them in our case for all your data
points to your mind we're trying to
minimize the total distance between the
points and the line that's a technical
way of saying we want everything to be
nice and fit as closely as possible okay
so now we've got the roughly drawn line
we want to find the equation of this
line how do we do this so we're down at
the moment but before this we did corner
geometry we look to what X trait lines
what information on here can help us to
find the equation of this blue line yeah
if I do the gradients and I can add on
one other piece of information
what would I add to that okay you've got
a lot of ideas that are useful but being
queer talking about the straight-line
chiapas you're probably talking about
between points to get the equation of
line if you have gradient do you
remember this yeah I heard it
those LRE yeah
Alwine this has got the gradient in it
and but it's also got the y-intercept B
now under normal circumstances that
would be a good way to find equation of
a line however I want you to look again
let me come back to the textbook and
presumably all looks similar if I draw a
line of best fit and it looked which
sorry I can't draw on top of this let's
go back here yeah there we go
I started virgin finish so put it that
was my line of best fit really really
super rough okay I know that this point
over here which is like 142 or something
like that that does look like your
widest sense doesn't it but I want you
to think I want you to remember what I
was putting your attention to over here
that 142 is not the y-intercept
why not lie with the viewer since L
graphed on the start at the zero this
straight line up here whoops this
straight line here is not the y-axis
it's just our what is the height axis
where it really should belong is
services are 90 at the moment will it go
18 17 16 15 all the way the y-axis is
like somewhere over there
right so the y-axis is going on here I'm
not going to be able to find where that
is unless you draw like an enormous
graph okay so now let's come back to
here if y equals MX plus B is not such a
useful way to go about this you may want
to turn back in your book we have lots
of ways to talk about equations of wise
one what else could you use say y -1
correct yeah okay so what is this this
have a name by the way do you want to
call this is called point graded fault
because you've got the point x1 y1 and
then you've got a gradient and okay this
is going to be more useful to me because
I've got lots of points on here a lots
of points and I can work out the
gradient okay but I'm going to go one
step further I think you could do this
it'll be fine but it's going to be
easier for you there's one other form
that I want to shoot
looks similar it looks like this do you
remember there for you what's on the
other side yeah I heard it y2 - very
good on okay now we spent a lesson on
this I wonder if you can see why I've
drawn an arrow from this to this
they're very closely connected see this
is two point four it's two point four
the reason why I connect these two
together is because how do you find the
gradient of a line any grandpa to rise
over run what's the formula for rise
over run is it isn't that it right there
that's gradient right so if you were to
put gradient in there the formula and
then rearrange you get the two-point
form that's how we actually derived it
this is a few couple of ecocide don't
mind if you can't remember okay so we're
going to try and use this guy is going
over here so if you have it write that
down
- point formula we're going to use two
point for me to try and find the
equation of this line okay now at this
point remember I mentioned to you we're
just doing this by eye so there's very
good chance that your line looks
different to the person next to you your
line probably looks different to mine as
well
we're just for the sake of consistency
so you're not too confused let's all
just imagine we're going to do numbers
just based on line since everyone can
see mine as well
okay what we want to do is we want to
find two points that are on this line
it's best to find two points that is
fire part as possible so I want you to
have a look at this point over here up
in the top right hand corner and I also
want you to look at say this is pretty
close this point over here in the bottom
left got a point here and a point there
okay I'm going to move this stuff out of
the way so that we can draw it there we
go
okay now help me out you can actually
see on this graph the coordinates if you
script I hope you can read down here
it's a bit it's a bit like you can
actually read the coordinates of these
points I'll give this other way as well
let's have a look at the one in the very
top right have a look at the vertical
line that it sits on there do you see it
if you can track it down I'll move the
the screen up a little bit if you track
it down all the way have a look at my
axes what do you read the x-coordinate
of that to be look carefully in the
scale so there's 24 26 I'll buy it
anyway that would make this 25 right
degree which make this 27 so I read that
in 26.5 UK with that 26.5 that's the
x-coordinate there okay so maybe you
want to cut that down we're writing
coordinates we usually write coordinates
like this
twenty six point five comma something
else okay I don't know something like
this let's go have a look I'm looking
for this y coordinate all the way over
here this one these in red keeps the 880
yeah so that's my y-coordinate so 26.5
cover 180 this is a point that's on my
line of the best fear so I'm going to
call this guy x1 y1 that's him okay now
let's have a look at the other point
it's down here in the corner here we go
so again I'm going to read down you're
familiar with the scale now what does
each section represent it's 0.5 it's
half a unit right so therefore this
point here is going to be twenty point
five and now when I go to the left so
you get to the Y
what are these ones each one to two
isn't it so that's going to be a hundred
and fifty-two so now I've got a second
point that's on my line of best fit x2
y2 I've chosen purple for this line so
sorry this coordinate so I'm going to
stay with that color x2 y2 equals twenty
point five that's my X and 152 that's my
Y okay all right so far so good this is
all the information I need now I'm going
to call
it's 2 point formula you might even like
to write 2 point formula